Hey guys, it's Justine, and I thought it would be really fun to do a year and seven month review of the AirPods.
I've had them since the very beginning and I think since the beginning,
especially right when I first got them, I had some mixed reviews
because for whatever reason, they would not stay in my ears. But now I think my ears have officially conformed to the AirPods.
And it's kind of crazy because I go running with them now, I work out.
I do all kinds of activities and they stay in my ear.
It's kind of shocking.
Very surprising especially because of the struggle that I had when I first got them.
So the AirPods and I definitely had a rocky first start off to our relationship because like I said, they didn't stay in my ears.
But now they do so problem solved.
They kept falling out in the most random and terrible places to fall out.
The first one being on airplanes.
I have crawled under so many seats. And especially in some of the seats when they get really wedged in there.
It's almost impossible to get out. I've had to have flight attendants help me. I've had to have flashlights,
I've had strangers digging on the ground, trying to help me find my AirPods.
So the first time that I'd lost my entire set of AirPods,
I was traveling and I just got back from Hawaii and I looked in my purse and I realized my AirPods aren't here.
I just got to the airport and I thought this is a problem because they're already sold out,
so even if I were to try to buy some now.
Even from the Apple store,
I wasn't gonna get them for another several months. That's how backorder they were originally.
So I freaked out as any Apple fan would who became obsessed with their AirPods.
I ordered a pair on eBay and they basically shipped the next day and I had them within three days.
I made a video I was freaking out,
I was upset, of course, I was being overdramatic just as iJustine would. And then,
I'd say maybe a month later, I found them. That meant that I now have two pairs of AirPods.
Which is actually quite helpful because I would always keep one of these inside of my laptop case.
So no matter what I'd always have a set with me when I was away.
The other one stays in my purse. That leads me to maybe another month or two later,
I thought that I had lost them again. I tweeted about it. I was upset, of course, overdramatic yet again.
But it was okay because I had the backup one. It all was well. Having two is definitely not necessary,
but of course I'm not complaining because it has been nice. And you're probably saying: well, Justine you still have two.
That's right because the missing AirPods
actually was found inside of my purse inside of like this secret little pocket that I didn't even know existed.
So back at two AirPods.
I tried a bunch of different AirPod accessories.
I tried a little string that wraps around your head and I was like, this is stupid.
Does this look good? They both fell out. I mean the good news is - oh gosh - if they fall out, they're both together.
If I tie this like arou... That's not gonna work.
My head's not... If it was a little bit bigger.
I also had one AirPod stop working.
Which was very upsetting because I was on a trip with my family actually, ironically going back to Hawaii.
If you guys haven't noticed, Hawaii is one of my favorite places in the entire world. I just love it.
Every time I go there I'm just instantly happy and overjoyed and inspired. I need to move there.
But while we were on the plane over there,
I was so sad because one of my air pod stopped working. Just completely, entirely stopped.
The good news, we were traveling to Oahu and there are two Apple Stores on that island.
So as soon as we landed, I made a Genius Bar appointment.
Went in, they replaced one of my AirPods and all was well. Trying to think if there's any other crazy AirPod stories.
There has been times where I'll be eating something and I'll have my AirPods just sitting here. I'll take them out,
I'll be like eating some snacks or something. And I can't even tell you, this has happened more than once,
than I'd like to admit that I've almost
eaten an AirPod because I keep thinking it's like some sort of like a sweet treat like a little snack.
Like I don't know what type of candy this would be. Like a popcorn.
I've also thought that this was like dental floss before. I'd also thought it was a pack of gum or like some Tic Tacs.
But no, AirPods.
Something that I'm really looking forward to, which I feel like Apple hasn't really been talking about, is the Powermat or the AirPower.
I call it something wrong every single time. So the next version of AirPods, it'll have wireless charging.
So with the Powermat you'll be able to charge your AirPods, your watch and your phone, all at the same time.
Which I'm just I'm honestly very excited for. I just hope that they announce something soon because I'm really really looking forward to it.
But yeah, just to be able to place these all down and have everything charge would be a dream come true.
Hopefully we'll hear more about that soon. But in the meantime, I'm still loving my AirPods.
Like I actually haven't found another pair of headphones that I like more. Don't know if I could even live without them.
I mean, I'm sure I could but do I want to? No.
The only time that I use real headphones is when I'm gaming. If I'm editing, I do need to use headphones
because sometimes the Bluetooth is lagging. And it doesn't have my edits on point with the music.
So then I do have to use them.
Even when I am editing, I end up just editing to the waveforms anyway, so it doesn't really make that much of a difference.
I've been loving these things, I'm looking forward to the next version whenever that happens to be.
Let me know in the comments below what you guys think. Do you love the AirPods? Do you not like them? Have you lost them?
How many have you lost. Surprisingly, I have bought these two and I have not officially,
permanently lost any of them. They've all made their way back to me.
Well, see you guys in my next video. If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you give it a thumbs up.
Also be sure to subscribe and even if you are subscribed be sure to hit the bell because that's the only way,
unfortunately, that you guys will be notified that I've posted a new video. Welcome to the new YouTube.
I'll see you guys in my next video, bye.